THAT HAVE EVER BEEN TAKEN.
CNN'S RACHEL CRANE HAS A LOOK AT
THIS MAJOR MOMENT FOR MANKIND.
>> AND LIFTOFF.
>> Reporter: SIX MONTHS AFTER
THE MOST POWERFUL TELESCOPE EVER
MADE LAUNCHED INTO SPACE, THE
TEAM INSIDE THE WEBB SPACE
TELESCOPE'S FLIGHT CONTROL ROOM
IS PREPARING TO REVEAL WHAT
ASTRONOMERS ALL OVER THE WORLD
HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR FOR
DECADES.
THE TELESCOPE'S FIRST FULL COLOR
IMAGES, WHICH ARE EXPECTED TO BE
LIGHT-YEARS MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN
THE TEST IMAGES RELEASED LAST
MONTH AND WILL INCLUDE THE
DEEPEST IMAGE OF OUR UNIVERSE
THAT'S EVER BEEN TAKEN.
>> OUR VIEW OF THE UNIVERSE IS
DEFINITELY GOING TO CHANGE ON
JULY 12th.
>> Reporter: HE RUNS THE SPACE
TELESCOPE SCIENCE INSTITUTE IN
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND, HOME TO
WEBB'S MISSION CONTROL.
AND HE PREDICTS THE DAY THAT
WEBB'S FIRST IMAGES ARE RELEASED
WILL BE ON PAR WITH THE DAY THAT
GALILEO BECAME THE FIRST PERSON
TO EVER POINT A TELESCOPE TO THE
SKY.
>> THERE WILL BE THE UNIVERSE WE
KNEW FROM BEFORE WEBB AND THE
UNIVERSE WE KNOW AFTER WEBB.
I REALLY MEAN THAT, I THINK OUR
PERSPECTIVE WILL CHANGE.
>> Reporter: NASA SAYS SOME OF
THE IMAGES TO BE RELEASED ON
JULY 12th STILL NEED TO BE
TAKEN.
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CAPTURED AND ARE BEING KEPT
SECRET.
BUT NASA'S LEADERSHIP HAS GOTTEN
A SNEAK PEEK.
>> WHAT I HAVE SEEN JUST MOVED
ME, AS A SCIENTIST, AS AN
ENGINEER, AND AS A HUMAN BEING.
>> A SENSE OF -- FRANKLY, I GOT
EMOTIONAL.
>> Reporter: BUT GETTING
EMOTIONAL ABOUT THE TELESCOPE IS
SOMETHING LEE FEINBERG HAS
LEARNED TO BURY AFTER WORKING ON
IT FOR DECADES.
A MICROMETEOROID STRUCK ONE OF
THE MASSIVE GOLDEN MIRRORS.
>> EARLIER IN MY CAREER IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A PUNCH IN THE GUT.
BUT WHAT I'VE LEARNED FROM
WORKING ON BIG PROJECTS LIKE
THIS, THINGS ARE NEVER AS BAD AS
THEY FIRST SEEM OR AS GOOD AS
THEY FIRST SEEM.
>> Reporter: HE WAS RIGHT.
THE TELESCOPE SURVIVED THE
STRIKE.
AND NASA IS NOW ON THE VERGE OF
HANDING THIS $10 BILLION
TELESCOPE OVER TO THE SCIENTISTS
WHOSE RESEARCH PROPOSALS HAVE
BEEN SELECTED FOR THE FIRST YEAR
OF OBSERVATIONS.
>> IT IS DOING AS WELL AS WE
COULD HAVE EVER HOPED IF NOT
BETTER.
SO I THINK THE SCIENTISTS ARE
GOING TO B